[Musica]
san giovanni è uno dei nostri paesi
della bassa abita a molinella qui vicino
quindi mi sento a casa e nello stesso
tempo con il mondo dei software siamo
nel mondo è quasi una magia e questa
magia la volevo condividere con voi
cercando di farvi capire come io in
questi anni di lavoro ho cercato di fare
il manager prima di tutto a parto da me
stessa sono una donna sono una
cooperatrice e come tale mi è sempre
venuto molto naturale mettere al centro
di ogni azione di ogni visione di ogni
gol di ogni cosa concreta da fare le
persone la società e soprattutto le
future generazioni
io mi chiedo sempre quando faccio una
cosa se questa cosa che faccio aiuta o
non aiuta il mio paese
il mio stato il mio essere italiano
insomma in qualche modo cosa succede
facendo questo fra vent'anni cosa
succede sto facendo qualcosa che dà o
che toglie o su solo ragionando nel
breve questo è un po il tema su cui pare
quindi in qualche modo ho cercato di
fare questo mestiere cioè essere un
manager rimarcando sempre che le cose si
possono fare quindi togliere gli
ostacoli ragionare su questo ma non da
soli insieme si può fare quindi mettendo
sempre al centro la squadra cercando di
far crescere le persone cercando di
valorizzare le competenze di tutti
cercando di mettere insieme figure
totalmente diverse che la vedono pensano
in modo diverso perché è un
arricchimento
la seconda cosa ho cercato di lavorare
sempre non solo insieme si può fare
insieme si può essere veri cioè in
qualche modo mai dimenticare chi sei
come paese
come nazione come persona che cosa puoi
dare su questo cioè con una sorta di
orgoglio per poter avere una visione del
futuro non pensare a un futuro che non
ha un passato non dimenticarci che noi
abbiamo una storia importante che i
nostri luoghi sono bellissimi
eppure ogni volta che andava all'estero
che faccio questo lavoro visitavo vivevo
i nostri centro città mi chiedeva ma
perché se tutti amano l'italia comprano
più sounding prodotto tra virgolette
contraffatto che italiano ma perché se
siamo il primo posto nel mondo
a voler essere visitati visitato siamo
un quinto paese per turisti ci sarà
qualcosa che stiamo sbagliando non è mai
colpa degli altri o penso penso sai che
sembra noi possiamo fare qualcosa noi se
noi viene prima del io è in tutti i
progetti in tutti i lavori che ho fatto
in tutti i momenti della mia vita
personale e professionale ho sempre
cercato di mettermi in discussione e di
capire se si può fare di più se insieme
si può fare a togliere dei vincoli in
questo momento per esempio mi sto
occupando di un progetto nuovo che si
chiama fabbrica italiana contadina che
sorgerà a bologna si sta costruendo in
autunno nascerà fabbrica italiana
contadina lo dice il nome ha cercato di
collegare gli opposti la fabbrica con la
terra che per anni era stata comunque in
antitesi rispetto a questo elemento qui
ha recuperato anche due nomi della
storia quelli veri quelli del fare non i
nomi che in qualche modo abbiamo
abituato o addolcito cercando di agire
negli ultimi tempi in fabbrica italiana
contadina ci sarà la nostra terra un
ettaro con tutte le cultivar 2000 ci
saranno gli animali 200 quelli delle
nostre spalle delle nostre ai è né più
né meno
ci saranno le fabbriche 40 che fabbriche
le nostre piccole grandi con tutte le
nostre i nostri consorzi da dove vengono
dalla sicilia fino al piemonte con una
grande integrazione mettendo in evidenza
il nostro territorio
facendoci capire che la nostra bellezza
e la nostra biodiversità la nostra
essere così diversi essere così
attaccati al fazzoletto di territorio
dove siamo nati pensando che sia sempre
il migliore e mettendoli tutti insieme
creando un sistema poi sarà un luogo
dove c'è la parte secondo me è più
importante la cultura dove la cultura è
senz'altro quella con la c maiuscola
quella che è nei nostri atenei che pensa
al futuro e la cultura dei nostri musei
dei nostri monumenti
ma la cultura dell'italia e anche il
nostro paesaggio e quel paesaggio che
disegnato dai contadini di a chi ha
lavorato la terra perché se pensate cosa
sono le langhe con i vigneti
cos'è la sicilia con tutti le aree gli
aranceti o gli ulivi dalla puglia
tutto questo e cultura allora noi in
questo luogo la vogliamo far vivere
portare avanti ma perché c'è bisogno di
un luogo di questo genere perché abbiamo
pensato di realizzare perché poi
d'italia perché a bologna e vengo sempre
al tema della visione del passato di
questo collegamento tra le generazioni
sia quelle attuali sia quelle comunque
che hanno fatto la nostra storia perché
ritorno al tema che siamo più desiderati
che visitati siamo più desiderati che
comprato il nostro prodotto non è
possibile
dobbiamo fare qualcosa allora uno dei
temi che si pone la grande complessità
dell'italia c'è la nostra forza della
nostra biodiversità
troppo spesso si tende a non valorizzare
l'insieme ma litigare per chi è meglio
che ovviamente se pensiamo a quanto è
grande il mondo e quante piccola
l'italia rispetto al mondo questo non è
un valore
quindi il creare un luogo dove come un
assaggio un piccolo assaggio puoi
ritrovare tutte le nostre
caratteristiche tutte le nostre
tradizioni ma anche tutto il nostro
futuro perché l'agricoltura cambia di
giorno in giorno
ecco questo in qualche modo era il
perché era importante
secondo noi farnush luogo unico di
questo genere perché in emilia perché a
bologna perché in qualche modo dentro
l'italia siamo la cultura la culla di
certe tradizioni
inoltre non ho sempre lavorato per non
farsi per fare delle tradizioni il
nostro futuro
ma come si può fare un luogo di questo
genere vengo sempre di più al tema
dell'interazione un nuovo di questo
genere si può fare per essere vero
perché deve essere un luogo vero
attraverso i veri protagonisti non si
può fare per terza persona in questo
luogo ci saranno le università migliori
ci saranno le aziende migliori ci
saranno i ristoranti di tutta italia ci
saranno comunque le rappresentazioni del
nostro paese ci saranno i borghi più
belli d'italia ci saranno rappresentati
i luoghi che in qualche modo fanno della
storia dell'italia un paese uni questo
ha voluto dire però queste due
componenti del perché la visione che
devi avere e nello stesso tempo come fai
a farlo la concretezza passare dalla
visione alla concretezza quindi al
pensare lungo e realizzare domani quindi
sempre questo elemento di sapere dove
devi andare sapere con chi vuoi andare
costruire con chi vuoi andare
come dare e avere la certezza che se
vuoi innovare di giorno in giorno la
strada non la sai mai la costruirà sai
che deve arrivare la che quella è la
meta ma per arrivare a quella meta di
volta in volta devi trovare una strada
che come dice sempre mio padre
la strada per raggiungere la mente non è
mai con la dritta e sempre storta a
tante curve alle volte anche molto
polverosa difficoltosa ma è quella che
tipo perché perché quella che ti
permette di ascoltare che ti permette di
deviare senza cambiare la meta questo è
lo sforzo nuovo che dobbiamo fare
ma ci deve essere in tutto questo un
terzo ingrediente il terzo ingrediente è
l'es
quello che io chiamo e mi piace chiamare
così e che deve essere manifestato
sempre di più nel nostro paese e il
nostro stile la nostra armonia di essere
italiano che è fatta di competenza che è
fatta di passione che è fatta di voglia
di confrontarsi e quando questa
competenza che noi abbiamo perché noi
veniamo dal rinascimento
noi abbiamo tante cose che il mondo ci
invidia e l'abbiamo se pensate bene
poche generazioni fa allora la famosa
scuola rinascimentale prevedeva che
c'era una sintesi perfetta tra il
visionario il maestro le maestranze che
erano capace di rendere unico ogni
piccolo cm tassello dell'opera non era
il rinascimento e knapp non perché c'era
solo una persona c'era di sicuro
comunque i visionari c'erano i maestri
ma le maestranze erano davvero un
tutt'uno
ecco io penso che il con l'ingrediente
di metterci assieme di vedere noi
insieme protagonisti con un po più di
orgoglio italia
noi possiamo contribuire in prima
persona a creare una sorta di nuovo
rinascimento italiano e di cogliere
l'opportunità che in questo momento c'è
nel mondo che sempre di più l'italia si
parla sempre di più d'italia si vuole
vivere e ve lo posso dire in prima
persona li faccio solo un esempio
concreto
sono stata due giorni fa a berlino alla
fiera internazionale del turismo la più
importante che sei in europa
dovevamo spiegare perché l'italia
diversa che cosa puoi avere in italia
spetta questo è anche fabbrica italiana
contadina con tutti i ragazzi e le
ragazze che lavorano con me vien detto
come facciamo a tra virgolette portare
una fabbrica in a berlino abbiamo
pensato che la fabbrica più facile da
portare a berlino tra le quaranta ce n'è
una che fa la sfoglia chiama sfogliamo
fa la pasta fresca di tutti i nostri
territori
mi ha detto invece di fare una
rappresentazione tra virgolette che
faccio sì la nuova di tagliatele faccio
uno mi ha detto le facciamo
invitiamo tutti i tour operator
invitiamo tutti i giornalisti
l'ambasciata e cerchiamo di spiegarli
che si può con conoscerli tagli anche
attraverso il cibo le ragazze supportati
dalle cesarine che hanno comunque una
storia quindi anche qui collegamento con
con tutte le età quindi con la
tradizione e il futuro hanno fatto 60
uova di tagliatelle
niente di strano per noi lo facciamo
tante volte ma vi assicuro che portava
in un mondo detto del business tutto
perfetto vestito in grigio e vedere che
tutto sommato qui le tagliatelle non
erano solo finte sono state fatte poi vi
giuro le hanno mangiate quindi erano
anche con il nostro sugo molto buona ha
fatto capire in pochissimo tempo senza
parole che noi abbiamo una grande
tradizione ma abbiamo un grande futuro
se siamo noi se smettiamo di lamentarci
e in qualche modo mettiamo al centro la
nostra bellezza la nostra storia grazie
[Applauso]